>>Narrator: It's October in
central Washington's wheat belt,
and in the township of Waterville,
everyone's on the lookout
for a tiny critter called
Phrynosoma Douglasii,
better known as the
horny toad lizard.
>>Man: Now when I was thirteen years
old, I drove a team of six horses
on a rod wheater, and I
saw lots of 'em there.
And they're nice little animals.
They eat bugs and they
do a lotta nice things.
>>Girl: We'd go into the dried
creek bed and wed flip over rocks
and my mom and I, we found
ten, right just along here.
>>I've got twenty-nine.
>>Man: Actually see more on the
roads than out in the field.
And you stop and then
you try to go out
and find them, and
sometimes it's hard.
And if you're in a snaky area, you
don't want to follow them too close.
>>I've found the horny
toads all under here.
>>Dig in it.
>>Narrator: For the past six years,
the lizard project has
been a key component
of the fourth grade
curriculum at Waterville School.
Local farmers volunteer their
time to record critter sightings
on data sheets provided
by the students.
>>I'd like to welcome
everybody this morning.
>>Narrator: On the first
day of the project,
the farmers bring their
information to school.
They meet their student partners,
and help them enter data on graphs
and charts which pinpoint the time.
>>It was just one, at three PM.
>>Narrator: Place.
>>That's too far over.
>>Narrator: And temperature
for each sighting.
>>Farmer: So then where
else do we go from here?
Do we have to log these
in on the computer?
>>Yeah Okay.
>>Narrator: The lizard data is
used by research Karen Dvornich,
as part of a University of Washington
program called NatureMapping,
an effort to quantify populations of
common species across the country.
>>Karen: The NatureMapping
program is really simple:
tell us what you see
and where you see it.
And all the schools, and all the
different communities provide
that information to us.
>>So this is all new science
for us, and it's just wonderful.
And we don't know what
the horny toads do.
We don't understand how
they live in the farmland.
We don't understand what
they do during the winter.
We don't know if they freeze.
>>Narrator: Working with fourth
grade teacher, Diane Peterson,
Dvornich helped design
core curriculum materials
around the yearlong project.
>>Diane: So we have to be reading
and writing and doing math--
>>Karen: When I saw what
the kids were supposed to do
at different age levels, I said,
"Oh, we have math, we have science,
we have technology, we have art.
We have all these components."
>>Student: How to catch a horny toad.
The first thing you have
to have is a good eye.
>>Diane: When we do
project based learning,
every learning style can be hit.
The kids can use their own
personal best learning style
to accomplish the goals.
>>Farmer: That's a good
picture, that looks just
like the ones I've seen, actually.
>>Diane: We've found
that for some kids,
drawing a scientific
illustration that's labeled
with all the correct scientific words
is a perfect way for them to shine
and to show what they know.
>>Student: The tail is right
there, it has stripes on it.
>>Narrator: During the project,
students learn sophisticated
computer programs like ArtView,
and they display their findings on a
class webpage at the end of the year.
>>Farmer: Okay, it's
twenty-six, twenty-three.
What maps do I need?
>>Diane: We start very simply with
some paper maps and we learn how
to find township range and section.
And now what does this
look like on the computer?
>>Farmer: Let's zoom into
this area right here.
>>Diane: And we practice,
and everybody has a turn.
It's a long process, and
there's a high learning curve.
The technology's easier for
the kids than it is for me.
>>Student: We need to
find T twenty-eight.
>>Diane: Involving
the farmers who may
or may not have had the
best experience in school,
getting them back into school
for a really positive experience,
they're just amazed at what the kids
know, and relationships are formed
between these kids and the farmers,
that go way beyond this project.
>>Mark: I don't like to call
these young people kids,
because kids are young goats.
These are young adults.
They've got a tremendous teacher.
>>Karen: So you want to
put your GPSs up this way.
Those six numbers, those
numbers you see there,
are satellites, circling the earth.
>>Wow!
>>Narrator: Later in the day,
students travel to a nearby field
to learn new techniques
in lizard tracking,
with the latest ground
positioning satellite technology.
>>Karen: They feel very comfortable
with any of the technology nowadays.
They follow their instructions
very well,
because they're serious about it.
>>You see that word "position?"
Tap on the position
and look for status.
>>It's not a field trip;
when we go out there,
the kids know that we're doing real
science and they're much more alert.
If it was just a field trip,
they wouldn't be there,
'cause what does it really mean?
>>So if we know where horny toads
are, we want you to go to that site
and we want you to write down that
latitude and longitude on your paper.
>>I've seen a huge difference
when the kids realize
that they are junior scientists.
I treat them as junior scientists.
I speak to them as junior scientists.
I don't simplify anything, I define
everything that I'm telling them
so they can use the same terms when
they wanna talk to another scientist.
>>Narrator: After receiving
their initial instructions,
the young scientists
took off at a gallop,
each hoping to be the
first to spot a lizard.
>>And watch if there's some
in there [inaudible] We're not
finding anything.
>>Narrator: But after
combing the area,
the only toad they found was the one
provided by researcher Megan Lahti.
>>See, there she is.
>>Narrator: She had attached a
radio collar to a toad's back
to demonstrate another
way of tracking.
>>Megan: And turn it on
and turn it loud enough
so that everybody can hear the beeps.
>>I think that this is far more
beneficial than a lot of the science
that I had done in my elementary
years, and I think the fact
that getting the kids
out into the field
and helping them understand science
as real professional scientists do,
using GPS and other technologies,
is very beneficial to them.
>>Do you see her?
>>All: Yeah.
>>Jessie: The first time that I found
out I was gonna be doing horny
toad work, I was really excited,
and it's really exciting today,
because I've been working
hard on these projects.
I was hoping to be a marine biologist
and a scientist, working with lizards
and stuff, so this is really fun
for me, and it gives me a heads
up on what I'm gonna do in the
future, maybe, if I make it, yeah.
And so that's pretty
much what I'm gonna do.
>>Oh, right here, right here.
>>Diane: I like to see kids
excited about learning.
>>Oh, sweet.
>>Diane: And that's what I see
when they're working
on a project like this.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to Edutopia.org